- Up, up, up, got it.
(mystical music)
- I kind of always thought of butterbeer
as like a fun thing.
- A slightly alcoholic magical beer.
- The first time Harry drinks
it, it warms his whole body.
- It makes you feel all
warm and fuzzy inside.
So, that makes me think that
butterbeer is damn good.
- I think Starbucks take on it will be--
- Butterscotchy.
- Sugary.
- I think there will probably
be some caramel in it.
- Like a Frappuccino.
- And like the creamy.
- I'm just gonna throw it out there.
I think maybe it's going
to taste a little magical.
(chimes ringing)
(mystical music)
- Accio--
- [Together] Butterbeer!
- Zing.
- I mean, it smells good.
- I only smell the caramel.
- Literally, only the caramel.
- It smells like a Yankee Candle.
- Oh my God.
- The color--
- Is interesting.
- Cheers.
- It's a Starbucks drink.
- That's not bad.
- It's very sweet.
- It tastes like my
first foray into coffee
when I would go to Starbucks,
and I would be like,
"Can I get an iced quad
venti two pump vanilla
"skim caramel macchiato
with extra caramel?"
- I'm a little disappointed.
- I will give it to my
child on their birthday
in a very small quantity.
- Not really butterbeery.
- Hold on, just like, I'm
going to close my eyes--
- Yeah, yeah, I'm going
to take your through it.
- And let's set a Harry Potter scene.
- It's cold.
We're at Hogsmeade.
We've got the scarves on.
It's snowing.
- Yeah.
- I can taste the magic.
(chimes ringing)
(mystical music)
- So, this one definitely
looks more like butterbeer.
- It looks like it will taste good.
- Maybe--
- Is it frozen?
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's a little more frothy on top.
- I can't get anything through the straw.
This baby is thick.
- I like this a lot.
- I guess, for what it
is, it's pretty good.
- This is a dessert.
- Like a dulce leche ice cream.
- It tastes like childhood.
- This is a drink that
you would definitely get
while you're waiting for your mom
to come pick you up in the movie.
- This is like if Honeydukes
sold a butterbeer.
- Yeah.
- Just sugar, sugar, sugar, sugar, magic.
- This one is more butterbeery
than the other one.
- It looks better, too.
- I would definitely drink this
if there was a special Harry Potter event.
- At first, I was like,
"Wow, it's really sweet,"
and now, I can't stop drinking it.
The more I drink it, the more I like it.
Is there crack in this?
- If you like Harry
Potter, you should try it.
- Yeah.
- I'll definitely be telling people that--
- I've experienced it.
- Go get yourself a
Butterbeer Frappuccino.
- But be nice to your Starbucks barista.
- All right, guys, thanks.
I've got to go to divination.
- Nerds, we're Harry Potter nerds.
(laughing)
(mystical music)